meantime watch out who's watching you on  social media debt collectors can now  contact borrowers through platforms like  facebook instagram and twitter the  consumer financial protection bureau  gave the green light this week with  certain restrictions their message must  be private and they have to include a  way to opt out of receiving additional  messages and if they try to friend you  they have to identify themselves as a  debt collector and heather john agreed  this part is wild to me of course people  should pay their bills but the fact that  a debt collector can now friend you is  crazy and i know someone a friend of a  friend who said like that happened to  them on instagram they were like who's  this person who followed me who's like  really professional in this professional  suit yeah  it's like who's bruce  right who's bruce oh bruce works it yeah  vacation there  how was that yeah  yeah how did you pay for that